While creating this course, I visited
Facebook with Dean Warren Solomon and spoke
with many data scientists. I learned a lot about EDA, and I'm excited
to share those stories with you throughout the course. First, you'll hear from
Aude to talk about what she finds most interesting about being a data scientist.
>> So what I really like is, being able to go from real world that, we have
like billions and trillions of rows of data. You don't know what's interesting.
It's like gigantic thing and you need
to, must investigate and have some ideas on
what might be interesting, and then try
investigating it, like, in different ways. Sometimes you
use, charts, sometimes you use maps and
sometimes you come across something that's, interesting and
that you want to, dig a little bit more into. And then eventually, once we have
figured out something interesting that we've developed the
corresponding algorithms, then the goal is to have an
impact on, either understanding the world or changing
the Facebook product. And being able to go from.
We have all this data, we don't know what to do with it. So like, we're going to
make a significant impact on like, understanding mobility
or improving Facebook. That's like a, a real awesome
flow of work.